when was the last time the place was
really properly cleaned it's cleaned
every Friday afternoon yeah
when was the last time all the fridges
were pulled out pulled out
um that was done about two weeks ago
what about all the bread rolls down
behind the fridge now you can see them
from here look that's what she throws up
into the uh well Donna throws bread up
into the basket to dry out dry out for
breadcrumbs
and she misses so it all goes down the
back of the fridge dirty lady
what about this kind of here what
about them
with a kitchen in this state Alex risks
further damage to lantana's already
fragile reputation oh you now it's
never been used
what about these trays there when were
they done
it could even be closed down that if we
do that yeah the oven doesn't stops
working
out are you ever going to tell me the
truth it does don't worry about the oven
breaking yeah that's replaceable giving
a customer food poisoning is not